i gotta say man this is something i
wasn't expecting
yeah this is i was not expecting this
because i mean i grew up
singing and dancing along to you guys
and then i watched this i was like
whoa like this is in the time you said
for yourself you're like
um these are these aren't like jobs to
you they're like having two dreams
when did you fall in love with uh
renovating
specifically farmhouses uh-huh um well i
think it started when i was
younger like my grandfather my uncles my
dad they were all builders
and um when we were i was maybe five or
s
three maybe three or five uh we moved to
this old historic
neighborhood in boston and that was like
my first
time seeing like older houses and it
just
became so intriguing to me like me and
my mother would get in the car we'd
drive around the neighborhoods and just
look at all the uh the different houses
and
that's when i just like fell in love
with with old houses
and then as soon as i was 20 i was like
i'm out of the city it was
it was too much so i moved up to the
town i'm in now i've been here
30 years and uh bought 20 acres and
just have been going strong since then
so is it something that you you know
when you decided you want to start
fixing things up
actually learning how to do it how did
you go about doing it do you find people
and go
teach me teach me everything you know
well when i was a teenager before
like when we were just starting out new
kids i would go to work with my dad
like on the weekends um and it started
out i was just
you know carrying his tools and lumber
and stuff like that
and then i just really fell in love with
it
and then um in 94 when new kids
uh disbanded i just started flipping
houses with a friend of mine and it's
just been
amazing ever since and you've done like
200 houses
i i can't even count anymore like i wish
i had an
accurate count but it's been a lot of
houses
so what's cool about this show you know
you talk specifically about your love
for farmhouses
right what is it what is your goal when
you go into putting uh
when you go into one of these projects
you call them like american treasures
and
you seem to to really want to honor the
history
of each of these homes yeah i mean so
many people go into a remodel
and they strip out all the old because
they want new
but i mean you can renovate a kitchen
and still keep the integrity of the
house without
you know just just things like if you're
gonna put an addition on your house
make sure it it matches what's there and
it doesn't
stand out like crazy so um
it's it's just a a real thought process
and really trying to educate
homeowners that they can fit what they
need in the space that they have
without really going crazy is that a
tough thing to convince people
that they don't need the brand new thing
that what they've got
is actually quite good but we can build
around this or restore it in a
particular way
yeah i mean it really depends on the
client some clients get it right away
and some just they
they have what they have in their mind
and that's what they want so
you know sometimes we fight back and
forth and and sometimes it goes my way
sometimes it doesn't but you know the
the important thing is is really just to
give them
what they want and and um
just make sure that it it all is
cohesive
with an old house yeah now
along with you on this ride on the show
is christina creston who's amazingly
talented
yeah what do you love working what do
you love about working with her
well i met her she was fresh out of
college and i was
renovating a a carriage house in on my
property and she pulled up
in this big huge pickup truck and jumped
out of the pickup truck and she's like
maybe like
five feet tall so she was just this
little
powerhouse and um i just knew at that
moment like
i i fell in love with her and our design
style is
so similar so she's so easy to work with
you know there's something i love about
the the approach that you guys have
taken to a lot of these projects like
there's an episode
where you renovate this chicken coop
yeah and it's like it's like nicer than
my house
chicken coop
you guys must have a particular joy in
working together and trying to figure
out how to make this stuff
come alive again uh-huh and things like
like chicken coops or just
you know i mean you're in there on a
daily basis
so you know i just think every space
should make you feel
like you want to be there and just be
warm and inviting and
you know like that chicken coop was the
best thing ever like
i could have sat out there for hours
just hanging out with the chickens you
know
that's awesome now you you did your own
farmhouse and we know that the plan was
this year that you know you were gonna
get married
yeah and so far i mean
you had massive plans it sounded like it
was amazing
where are you guys at right now in terms
of planning it do you do you know what
you're gonna do
um no i mean covet has thrown everybody
for a big loop
so um here in the states we're finally
getting back
to normal like you don't have to wear a
mask in public
and you know stores are all open and
restaurants are open
um so who knows you know
i mean we've been together 13 years now
so we're we're kind of just like
that's that's the main thing that we
survived covet and
being around each other 24 7 for like
three months so
you know the relationship is super
strong and
we'll we'll just keep figuring it out
from here
one of the fun through lines in the
story
of your show is that you know every now
and again you got to leave
yeah and you got to do things with new
kids which is again it's like that
that other side of the coin which is
such a cool thing you know between
renovating homes and doing concerts
what is actually the hardest thing on
your body what's actually
more tiring for you oh renovating homes
i mean it's
it's a lot of physical labor i come home
at night and i'm like
pop three advils and like just go to bed
um you know touring is is more a mental
drain on you you know it's it's being on
a bus going from city to city to city
you never really have
that sense of home um you know but both
are equally great things i mean i have
like
the best life that i get to do two
things that i love and
you know with the new kids it's good
that we tour three months out of the
year and then i have
the rest of the year just to do my thing
be in the yard
all that fun stuff are there plans as
things are opening up
as the world is so slowly coming back to
normal to do something big
to do a big like new kids let's get back
to business thing
yeah i mean there's a lot of uh shows
opening up
states um it's we we kind of just have
weekly calls and just try to figure out
what's
you know what's what's doable what's not
so
i mean i know definitely we will be
touring next year
because i think by then everything's
just gonna be
you know back to normal um as far as
this year i
we still have no idea if
if something goes wrong at jordan's
place
or dina's place or anything are they
calling you up i'd like
i i need your help i need your advice
man how do i
yeah my brother he's he's actually
he surprises me uh you know with his his
design skills and all that stuff but um
no we've we've done i've done a few
things at my brother's house
um danny's daughters are always calling
me asking me to come build them
closets they want these huge master
closets
and uh donna he's he's way too far away
out in chicago so we don't we don't get
out there much to to see what he's got
going on
yeah how's how's donnie doing since uh
since his mom passed
wow yeah that's that's a tough one i
mean
his mom was everybody's mom you know she
was just
the sweetest soul and you know just
such a part of all the new kids lives i
mean all
our mothers just since day one have have
guided us through this crazy business
and
kept us grounded um you know
so it's just yeah it's it's it's so
heartbreaking
yeah but it's good that you guys have uh
you guys are there for each other you
know what i'm saying
yeah why not well jonathan thank you so
much for your time man congratulations
on the show
awesome and yeah i love that design
style that you guys have i got a
i got to do a wallpaper on my on my
little
den down here that's a little chicken
coop wallpaper i dig that
i steal that idea so you put gordon at
home
yeah wow that's cool
man that's how we're doing now yeah
all right good talk to you man good
talking to you all the best
all right take care
you